[Music]
it's beautiful amigo perfect but useless
I have something for you Diego give me
your hands
papa
no the roulade is simple it has four
basic parts the shell which contains the
explosive defuse the handle and of
course the pin what do you think breathe
the pin simply off the handle in place
it is only when you let go that this
grenade goes boom follow me
now
[Music]
I am El Presidente which means that
someday you will be our president
and our people they do not know how to
be happy they are torn apart by opinions
noise indecision strangled by their own
freedoms and even if you have love in
your heart you and if you want what's
best for them if you only want to save
them from themselves
they will hate you do everything you say
you believe will be wrong
[Music]
[Applause]
they will ask their you screams
for you evil
a monster
this
[Music]
so you tell me
are you moving
are you a pastor
our country is like this grinning exempt
he has two basic parts
and new and you must clutch them knives
and died up or we all
we
[Applause]
you understand now
you